قرار رئيسي مهرجان القاهره السينمائيه
حسين فهمي بان يكون لدرس كود ملزمه لكل من
يحضر المهرجان هذا العام فتح ابواب النقدي
والرفض على درسكم في مصر فكل ما هو مفروض
مرفوض
[موسيقى]
لكنه ليس الوحيد فسبقى ان شهدان وكان
السينمائي الدولي في عام 2015 من عام
ممثلات من السير على السجاده الحمراء
اداره المهرجان
الذين يرتدون احذيه مريحه
ادريس كود في جميع انحاء العالم بات عرضه
للجد والجدي والنقاش فقبل سنوات حاول
اربعه نواب برلمان في الفلبين تعديل قانون
سياسه الباب المفتوح الذي يسمح لاي شخص
زياره المباني الحكوميه او حضور اجتماعتها
شورت ارتداء ملابس مناسبه النواب الاربعه
الاسعار
هي ان يميز ضد المواطنين الفقراء الذين
يؤدون زيارته مبنيه الحكومي او حضور
اجتماع لكن لا يمتلكون ملابسه مناسبه
[موسيقى]
انا عماني الماضيات من وباء كرونه اللذان
شهدنا خلالهما الاغلاق والعمل والدراسه عن
بعد ربما ساهم في التعجيلي بانهاء منظومه
الدراسكوت فقد استطعنا الانتاج والعمل
والدراسه والنجاح ونحن نرتدي البيجامه وقد
يعني ذلك ان مسمارا اضافيا دقه في نعشق
الدراسكوت لصباح العربيه
[موسيقى]